water
[Music]
earth fire hey everybody its Charlie I
got a lot of requests to do the Avatar
The Last Airbender season 4 video Aaron
he has dropped a bunch of teasers for
what their plans were for Avatar The
Last Airbender had it goddess season 4
they'd already started to make plans for
that right around the time that the
live-action movie was getting ready to
ramp up so I know there's a lot of
conflicting reports about what was going
on with Avatar season 4 were they going
to do it were they not going to do it he
goes into a pretty great detail about
what was going on behind the scenes so
we'll break it all down and talk about
the storylines that they were going to
do particularly Azula because he said he
has some special plans for the Azula
character so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Avatar The Last Airbender videos
they've got the new Netflix series
that's supposed to premiere sometime
next year tentatively but that might
change a little bit I will do videos for
it as soon as it gets here so we just
broke this down top-10 style so a lot of
people ask what happened to Azula after
the events of the TV show even if you
don't know what their plans were for
season 4 or you haven't read the comics
she still is alive in present-day she
hasn't been confirmed dead yet and in
the world of Avatar The Last Airbender
and Legend of Korra unless you see
someone dead or another character tells
you that they're dead they're still
alive out there somewhere just waiting
to come back
[Music]
tuff nice to see you again Twinkle Toes
that's why at the beginning of Legend of
Korra when they're talking about what
happened to all the original characters
from last airbender and you see them
flashback to their adult forms you learn
about Sokka dying so there are some
characters that came back in present-day
Zuko being one of the biggest ones to
come back along with Toph but assuming
that the events of Legend of Korra are
meant to be present-day in present-day
Azula would be in her early 90s just
because she's really close in age to
Zuko and he's about ninety-one during
the last season of Legend of Korra so at
the end of season 3 she completely flies
off the deep end and starts to go crazy
when she's ready to be crowned Fire Lord
of the Fire Nation
Zuko challenges her to the comet
enhanced Agni Kai and they just
completely go at it it's an amazing
battle
then once Katara mobilizes her with her
waterbending she completely loses her
[ __ ] and they lock her up and that's the
last we saw or heard about her until
they started the comic book series which
sort of continued that storyline but
here's the thing
typically comics aren't always canon to
the main series there's a little bit
different for the Avatar The Last
Airbender comics and The Legend of Korra
comics because the creators are working
on them themselves
so technically anything that they work
on as canon in the comics pick up right
after the events of Avatar The Last
Airbender season 3 we find out what
happens to Zuko's mom I'll probably do a
separate video about that because that's
like a whole other hour we could spend
talking about that but while they were
still in the planning phases and they
might have actually done the season
forward this is what Aaron hee-haws said
about the actual storyline and he
focuses specifically on Azula so he says
I always intended for Azula to have a
Redemption arc in the story of Avatar
The Last Airbender and he starts this
giant thread this was all back in April
just a little while ago he goes on to
say it would have been longer and far
more complicated than Zuko's she had not
bottomed out yet at the end of season 3
if you thought that this was her
completely off of her rocker apparently
they had planned for her to go even
crazier over the top but then at her
deepest moment in her own abyss she
would have found Zuko
her brother they say despite it all her
brother Zuko would be there for her
believing in her sticking by her doing
his best to understand and help her hold
her pain that she could no longer hold
alone
Zuko patient forgiving and
unconditionally loving all strengths he
had gained from uncle Iroh so it would
have been more of Zuko repaying a lot of
the lessons that he got during his life
changing field trips with team avatar
and uncle Iroh giving that to Azula in
her future arc what everyone else went
on a life-changing field trip with Zuko
now it's my turn
he goes on to say that's how she would
have gotten out and changed with the
faith and love of someone she had hurt
but who had stuck by her anyway just as
he had been saved by the faith and love
of someone he had hurt but who stuck by
him talking about team avatar although
you could also say uncle Iroh - because
he did push him away for a long time
then he goes on to say I'd always
imagine that after coming out on the
other side she would be one of those
people who hilariously over shares her
own feelings all the time and that she
would be a bit over apologetic like a
Canadian version of Azula which does
sound kind of funny
Canadian Azula then obviously because
people were just bombarding him with
questions to clarify a lot of this and
what was going on with their original
plan he answered a bunch of questions -
saying it wasn't an April Fool's joke
because he posted this on April 1st so
people are like is this crazy avatar
season four story just an April Fool's
joke he says not an April Fool's joke
oops
picked a bad day for my earnest thoughts
on azula's Redemption path he always
believed there would be a fourth season
and then when people were like you know
wait a minute that's not exactly what
people said in the past like Bryan and
Mike said they planned on doing three
seasons and that was it so his answer to
that was is that they originally planned
on three at the very beginning then they
discussed a fourth and it seemed like
they were gonna do it then M night
Shyamalan came on and they reverted to
the original plan because the movie was
ramping up and Mike and Bryan wanted to
focus more on helping him make that
movie even though when you listen to
interviews after the fact Mike and Bryan
say that they tried to help out with the
development of the Avatar The Last
Airbender a live-action movie but all of
their notes and all their input really
just got pushed to the side so almost
nothing that they contributed to that
actually made it to screen which
actually makes me feel better because
you already kind of bummed that we
didn't get another season of Avatar The
Last Airbender like that would have been
so cool but then to hear that they
bailed on that I
to focus on the movie which wound up
being terrible if they had actually been
responsible for some of the stuff that
happened during the movie it would have
been soul-crushing but the saving grace
of it all at the end of the day is that
they can now say because all their ideas
were thrown out that they had absolutely
zero to do with what happened with that
live-action movie because the comics are
candid - the main series though we
actually do know what happened to Azula
for the couple years after the events of
Avatar The Last Airbender series so each
one of the different comics like the
promise the search smoke and shadow the
rift those take place about one year
right after the other so they just
slowly aging up so they're still pretty
young but it's still a long time before
the events of the flashbacks that we saw
during Legend of Korra when they're in
their 30s early 40s so right at the end
of Avatar The Last Airbender
Azula gets locked up after this fight
here Zuko is officially crowned Fire
Lord
Aang is there and is this nice
celebration in an end to the Hundred
Years War it's a nice reference to the
flashbacks that we got with Roku when he
was giving in all this history and you
saw the flashbacks to when he was the
avatar with his best friend at the time
who was Fire Lord Sozen he was the
person that started the Hundred Years
War that's why they call it sozin's
comet so sort of bringing things full
circle right after that the comics pick
up with the promise which is sort of the
story of early Fire Lord Zuko stays and
him trying to deal with a lot of the
lingering issues from the Hundred Years
War so they have all these Fire Nation
colonies in the earth nation that they
have to deal with but they do bring a
Zula back and you learn what he did with
her after the end of the events of the
Avatar The Last Airbender finale
Ozai himself was thrown in prison
because he was such a danger to everyone
and they were still alive
Ozai loyalists within the Fire Nation
itself so there was a lot of worry that
he would come back and try to retake his
throne from Zuko but because azula's
mental state had broken down so much in
Zuko took pity on her he put her in a
mental institution the year after that
Zuko goes on a quest to find out what
happened to his mother and finds out
that as Ulla has a bunch of letters that
their mother had sent her that she had
kept from him their whole lives so
there's a secret correspondence that he
never knew about he gets really upset
she burns all the letters in demands to
be taken with him on the quest otherwise
she
give him critical information that he
needs to track their mother down so the
story of the search is literally that a
life-changing field trip that they take
Azula on she's a total problem child to
them the entire time she tries to escape
constantly and gets super pissed off
she's still hallucinating things she
hallucinates their mother she starts to
twist a lot of the memories of their
mother in her mind because you don't
really get a sense for how she felt
about their mother during the actual
series she only talks about her a couple
times briefly but as much as you would
think that they'd focus on Zuko's mental
state and how he deals with the idea of
finding their mother after she's been in
exile for so long a lot of the story
really does cover what's going on in
azules head which i think is a really
big payoff for fans she's such an
amazing complex character within the
world of Avatar that the more you get to
learn about her the better the more
interesting she seems so this just tries
to continue that idea I will do a
separate video at some point explaining
the full story of what happens while
they're searching for their mother when
they find her what they do with her and
what happens after that
but eventually they do find their mother
Azula winds up escaping and she just
goes off into the wild never to be seen
again for a little while till she comes
back she resurfaces during the smoke and
shadow comic book and it's a couple
years after the events of the surge so
she seemingly got her [ __ ] together
while she was running around in the wild
but we learned that she takes on this
persona to try and push Zuko in a more
hardcore direction and she explains that
she no longer wants to usurp the throne
in her role now as she views it is to
guide Zuko to a more hardcore path to
turn him into a person that's more like
their father Fire Lord Ozai as you would
expect at the end of that storyline she
disappears again seemingly escaping in a
puff of smoke she reappears briefly in a
sort of end tag scene but then
disappears again so obviously she's
still alive somewhere out in the world
but that's all while the avatar
characters are in their early 20s but
like I said during The Legend of Korra
flashbacks they're in their late 30s so
there's still just a whole bunch of
unanswered time about what azula's been
doing in what she's doing in present day
if she didn't die sometime after the
events of what's going on in these
flashbacks which I'm assuming she did
not so the beauty of this new avatar the
last airbender Netflix series that are
doing these new episodes expanded
storylines is that they can cover a lot
more Azula stuff that's going on you can
actually spend more time in her head
than you did during the original series
if they do want to go beyond the events
of the finale because this was a huge
moment to go out on and they want to do
some of the comic-book stuff like say if
the TV show went for four or five
seasons then they'll have to find some
way to completely re-engineer that plot
because day of the comet is such a huge
moment to go out on that is just weird
if you have a little tag after that that
doesn't seem quite as big like you have
this amazing season 3 or season 4 ending
depending on how they plot it out and
then you have a fifth or sixth season
with stuff that doesn't seem quite as
cool so what I do think is going to
happen is is that there will be some
changes from the original storyline as
part of the adaptation to just plan out
because of however many seasons they're
intending they haven't revealed a total
episode count or what that's going to be
it's always a little bit different for
live-action shows than it is for
animated shows so if we get any news
about that of course I'll do a video
well let me know in the comments what do
you want them to do with Azula in this
new Avatar The Last Airbender Netflix
series if there's any avatar videos that
you guys want me to do just let me know
in the comments below what you wait for
everything click here for my other big
video about the new Netflix episodes
that they're doing and click here for
that brand new Rick and Morty's season 4
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight
you
[Music]